le procès de l'absurde et de l'abject
les assises d'indre et loire juge
pendant deux jours un homme accusé
d'avoir tué son ami sur le parking d'une
guinguette pour une question d'argent il
a mis le feu à sa voiture dans laquelle
il dormait c'était en 2018 à pouze est
au tribunal de tours on retrouve lucas
chopin il y à des affaires plus tragique
que d'autres traités aux assises c'est
le cas aujourd'hui et demain alors que
yoann 23 ans comparaît devant la cour
d'assises d'indre et loire pour
destruction de bien d'autrui par un
moyen dangereux pour les personnes ayant
entraîné la mort le matin du 19 août
2018 a pousé l'accusé appelle les
secours pour un incendie de voiture dans
laquelle se trouve son ami placé en
garde à vue l'homme reconnaît avoir
allumé ce feu je le cite je voulais lui
faire peur j'ai été dépassé par les
événements le mobile invoquée c'est un
soupçon de vol d'argent de la part de la
victime sur fond d'une intense
alcoolisation
l'enjeu de ce procès n'est pas de
démontrer une intention de tuer puisque
yoann n'est pas accusées de meurtre mais
il va falloir déterminer précisément les
moyens employés pour la funeste
entreprise liquides inflammables ou
simple papier et volonté ou pas de venir
en aide à la victime car ce qui ressort
de l'appel passé au secours et diffusée
lors de ce procès ce sont les
différentes excuses trouvé par johan
pour ne pas sortir la victime de la
voiture malgré les demandes des pompiers
parmi les autres temps forts du jour la
diffusion d'une photo du corps calcinés
de la victime en début d'après-midi
silence pesant en salle d'audience avant
les exposés des experts le verdict dans
cette affaire sera connue demain soir
yoann encourt la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité soit une peine plus lourde
que s'il avait comparu pour meurtre